hello I feel like I've had your family
here at this point on this show I've had
a couple of your kids I'm just saying
I've had a lot of your family here well
one time you should bring us all
together here I know exactly will it be
more exciting are y all fun at
Thanksgiving it would be great yeah
absolutely yeah awesome it's great Paul
I know have you youall met obviously
right yeah yeah of course I mean he has
played several times when I did the
Letterman show
exactly we have a funny we have got a
funny connection though you and I I
don't know if you realize this but
before you were you know a great
politician you made a an album a vinyl
album called Arnold Schwarzenegger's
total body workout you working out to
the hits of the 80s and you worked out
to one of my songs it's reigning men
that I co-wrote with Paul Jabara you
have one two up down
up I'm telling you I want to go to the
studio with you too I think oh my God
you like the original playlist guy
making playlist that's why that record
was such a big hit was not because of me
going up and down and doing my squats
and my leg lifts and all those things
but because it was of your music well
you are no fool I mean I know exactly I
have good taste when it comes to music I
know you all know that you must love
mine okay um I'm just
kidding I'm just kidding um Welcome to
our mus exactly you're like I'm only
coming for the music no Welcome to our
studio this is our our first season here
in New York we're very excited and we're
the do you remember like when you first
moved over here like do you have a first
memory of New
York um I remember coming here in
1968 and uh traveling through New York
then going to Los Angeles and living on
Muscle Beach yeah uh but then I came
back in 1969 and won the Mr Universe
contest for the fourth time here in uh
in New York and so I remember that and
then right after that I was offered to
do this movie in New York yeah there was
a really great beginning I I finally
realized my dream and then afterwards I
chased my dream and continued taking
acting lessons and uh then my movie
career took off and it was one of those
kind of Lucky things when you first
moved here though you obviously have a
thick accent still so I do too welcome
to Texas um but but I have an accent you
what so weird um no I was I was just
going to say when you moved here was
there a lot of like Lost in Translation
when you're having conversations with
people like you thinking you're saying
something and they hear something else
yeah it's very difficult to adopt to a
new language you know this this I
remember that uh right on the beginning
a friend of mine a Jewish friend of mine
said they says I know Austrian food at
this this Hungarian restaurant uh on
Fairfax Avenue he says I'm going to take
you there so he took us there and I ate
this unbelievable you know vegetables
and the meats and everything like that
and then I said to the guy to the owner
he came to the table he says can I help
you with you want some more and I said
yeah can I have some more of your
garbage your garbage yes and so my
friend so he say what do you call my
food what do you say say this again what
do you call my food you call garbage and
then my friend jumped in and says no no
no what he actually meant was cabbage he
want your cabbage I me things like that
will come up was like crazy yeah know
but I mean he understand after oh
cabbage you want Mo to cabage yeah yeah
cab sorry pretty bold of the guy though
like you looking like you and like him
being bold enough to be like what did
you say I don't know if I I'd have just
been exactly it's garbage by I would
have just left um I heard this crazy
story it's random and I have to know
what St did you accidentally break a
first lady's ankle and how does that
happen if
so well um George Bush invited me when I
was the chairman of the president's
Council of Fitness he would invite me
always to Camp David this was 1991 92 uh
when he was president he would invite me
up there literally like every month he
loved hanging out with me and working
out with me we do throwing horseshoe and
you know going running up there and all
the stuff and uh I was one time up there
in the winter and so he said to me he
says I have this great sled which was
not really a sled it was a the bargan
yeah and and uh so with sleds you can
steer the sled with the with your feet
uh but that one I couldn't really steer
so we go down the hill in the snow there
he's sitting behind me and he says you
steer and I didn't not know how to steer
so so we just going faster and faster
and all of a sudden we're approaching
this tree and all of a sudden Barbara
comes out behind the tree and then we
just ran into her leg and uh and so the
poor Barbara Bush you know she was like
she had to go to the hospital afterwards
she had the you know a sprained leg and
she got a cast on it and the whole thing
like that but I have to say that they
were very gracious about it and the way
they they took it and uh you know I I
apologize I I feel really bad nobody has
this story that's incredible she was a
wonderful first lady so we want to talk
about your new book so it's called be
useful seven tools for life wait I have
it right here
so um how did you come up with seven
like it feels like did you know the
number was going to be that like how did
you come up with that number key thing
is that you pick specific things that
really helped you in life and that make
your life fortunate as as my life is and
just extraordinary and to be successful
but I think it's important to mention I
always say I'm not a self-made man
because so many people write stories
Schwarzenegger is an example of a
self-made man and how always say I'm not
because I said everything that I've
achieved is because of the help of other
people AB you know some American brought
me over to America Joe weer I remember
he brought me to America there were the
training partners that helped me all the
time to train and to become Champion I
there were bodybuilders that brought
over dishes to my apartment blankets
pillows a black and white TV a radio I
mean all this stuff I mean you have no
idea what this feels like when you are
this immigrant this Foreigner that has
$20 in his pocket when I came over here
and then all of a sudden people show
this generosity and help you like that
this love and inclusion it's it's
important to to recognize that you're
not a self-made man because then you you
realize how many people helped you and
then you realize how many people you
have to help also they helped you now
you have to give something back and I
have to help other people that's why in
a book the last chapter is break your
mirror you know the mirror that makes
you always look at yourself yeah break
that mirror and just look beyond that
and you will see the millions of people
that need your help that's why in in the
70s I got involved with Special Olympics
and I started becoming the national
trainer and then the international
trainer and then later on I became the
chairman of the president's Council of
Fitness uh on President Bush and then
lay on I started after school programs
because I realized that there 70% of the
kids come from families that where both
of the families are working yeah both
the parents both of the parents are
working so so now there's no one there
for the kids in the afternoon so what
happens or there's just one parent in
the household so they have to have
somewhere to go yeah it's a it's a major
major challenge programs are very
important because it gives you in the
afternoon we provide tutoring for the
kids and the U that's amazing homework
assistance Sports programs uh Arts
programs and all that and just the key
thing is to have adult supervision so
they are between 3 and 6:00 having a
great time studying getting better in
different areas exactly and their
education improves tremendously and the
grades improve it tremendously so it's
it's really a win-win situation and the
parents can work without having the
headache so this just one of the things
that I do to give back to the community
and then of course when I ran for
governor I I turned my back on doing
movies every year and making this $20
million a movie a year and then just
said okay I'm going to go and just be a
public servant Serve the People of
California so but when you're blessed
giving back yeah yeah yeah I I agree
with that I agree with that well I want
to come back to the one you were talking
about earlier breaking mirrors so it's
it's open your mind and break mirrors
right what exactly does that I love that
opening your mind is is another chapter
in there which is you know open my mind
and shut your mouth yeah oh because yeah
because you know what I could use that
one no no but I'm telling you because uh
I wanted to just let people know that I
one of my The Secret of My Success was
that there always was like a sponge I
listened very carefully of what people
have to say I am a very good listener
and I think it really helped me in my
career helped me in my acting career it
helped me in my political career that it
was more interested in listening rather
than talking and uh so I think it's just
one of those things because so many
people are so concerned about you know
what they have to say but you don't
learn anything if you say is moving you
learn when you listen you know God gave
us two ears and only one
mouth so so we might as well just listen
twice as much and talk less I mean
that's what the what the I feel God sent
you here today for
me I feel like I feel like this is an
intervention and my crew is
like well let's do another break this is
incredible everybody yall got to go get
this Arnold's new book is called be
useful seven tools for life it's out now
and everyone in the audience is getting
a
copy you can also Find Arnold's P
newsletter
[Music]
[Applause]
online thank you guys y'all have a great
night guys I'm going
home